instead of trying to think up content I
became the content and I had this camera
guy that I hired and his name was
Sebastian and he kept popping in Brad
got to make content I'm like dude give
me a minute five minutes later Brad
gotta make content so I'm getting all
frustrated and and so he popped in
one too many times and he said Brad
gotta make content and I looked at him
and I said dude turn the camera
on I am the content but then I went back
and I finished my call and then another
person called and I closed the deal then
an employee walked in and I talked to
the employee and I forgot that he was
filming me the whole entire time and
believe it or not that's when the
started blowing up that's when I started
getting like thousands and thousands of
followers and comments and engagement
and the reason why is because